foreign
[Music]
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where that is dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships
number one best-selling author Ramsay
personality and host of the Ken Coleman
Show Ken Coleman is my co-host today as
we talk about your life and your money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five David starts us
off this hour in Dallas hi David how are
you
absolutely how can we help
yeah so I am um I need some advice I'm
29 years old uh when I was when I was
younger I made some some poor academic
choices so I don't have any you know
useful degree or really any good skills
for the job market
um so uh a few years ago things turned
around and I got married and I moved to
Switzerland where my wife is from and I
landed a good job there I was just
really fortunate
um at a good company and my plan was to
stay there and just work my way up and
that was going to be my life
unfortunately about three months ago um
something happened and my wife and I got
divorced so I moved back to the States I
moved to Dallas to be around friends
that are you know supportive and that's
where I am now so I am an adult I am
living at a friend's house I don't
really own any professions I don't have
any money no car I'm starting over
um over here and I do not want to live
you know I don't want to be at
retirement age still living paycheck to
paycheck um I I'm willing to do pretty
much whatever it takes if it's going
back to school or whatever
um I need an actual career um and I need
to learn how to properly manage my
finances but I have no idea where to
start with any of this
um I'm at a Crossroads here in my life
so I'm wondering what advice you would
have or what you guys would do in my
situation well the first thing I would
do if I were you is get a job and it
doesn't have to be anywhere remotely
close to what you might think a dream
job is it may not even be a great job
but it's a good job meaning it's in a
decent environment and you are somewhat
valued or respected right and and you're
able to make some money I think this is
crucial because you've just gone through
some enormously difficult emotional
stuff relationship stuff and I love that
you've landed in a safe place with some
friends but you need to get out and
start doing something and I don't think
it's the cure-all I want to be very
careful I don't think that work is the
Silver Bullet but I do believe in the
data shows us that when a person is
doing something productive and in this
case it's earning a paycheck getting you
to a place where you can get financially
stable get out of your friend's house
and off their couch and living on your
own is going to do wonders for the
healing process it's not the healing
process but it's going to do wonders so
I think that's the first thing and so
once I do that then I'm going to start
to say okay now that I I'm getting some
breathing room I want to get my
financial house in order I'm going to
come up with a plan and we've got the
plan here through the baby steps now I'm
looking towards what do I really want to
do what work is Meaningful for me what
results motivate me now I want to call
something out and I know you're down on
yourself but I want to encourage you
you started off the phone call by saying
you didn't have any skills that were
transferable but that's completely
untrue because you work successfully in
Switzerland
true or false
yeah that's correct so let's get rid of
it what were you doing there I worked
for a company doing running their social
media and editing videos did you enjoy
it
yeah yeah I did did you suck
no I don't think so okay so let's go
there first I mean really so you know
how to edit and do social media uh again
that's a valuable skill
so never again are you allowed to say I
don't have any valuable skills okay okay
because Ken's right it's just not true
okay I've I've been I've been since I
got here I've been doing whatever I can
um to earn money my my
issue is because I grew up um with
hard-working parents but far under the
poverty line so
um my fear is that I I don't advance I
don't um you know I want to financially
be set when I'm a little older you know
um yeah Step One is get off the street
yeah and get a car yeah and so Step One
is go do anything and a lot of it uh to
pile up some money right anything is
legal and moral you need to be doing
like 60 or 80 hours of that
um or three things uh and so you can get
your little pile of money get off the
street get a couch get a bed you know
get get a get a car and then we can
start talking about self-actualizing and
moving into the career of your dreams
and becoming uh you know moving from
paycheck to purpose as Ken's book says
and we'll send you a copy of that and as
you're doing that then you just keep
listening to this podcast and we'll walk
you through with the Ramsay materials
and Financial Peace University those
kinds of things how to handle the money
once you've got something but right now
you just got to get sustainability right
right okay and but from your background
uh you know it it's the tapes that are
playing in your head that I want to you
know that earning a little money will
shut those tapes off
I'm gonna be I'm gonna be below the
poverty line I'm gonna be stuck here no
you're not
I mean you can do social media and you
can edit videos and you're freaking in
Dallas Texas I mean come on there's
about a bazillion things you can do
there that will earn you fifty to a
hundred thousand dollars a year starting
tomorrow Ready set go okay go okay you
know you are not gonna be your childhood
you're just simply not
um but you've had the crap kicked out of
you and so that those little boy tapes
play in your head during your pain time
and uh that's just normal uh we all have
those we all have those you know the
doubting Thomas that sits on our
shoulder right uh and he's particularly
loud she's particularly loud when other
people have rejected you like your wife
that's a very good point and I'm gonna
tell you something that's happening to
you David when your wife whatever reason
decides to not be married to you anymore
there's a personal worth that gets
attacked and that personal worth can
translate over to professional worth and
I think Dave you're absolutely spot on
that's a natural thing does it make you
weak does it make you weird you're
you're human and you're hurting yeah I
went and I went through bankruptcy and
you know 28 years old I'm sitting there
thinking you're the king of the doofuses
right you know and it took me a little
while to you know turn in my crown
I like that
uh it's true I kind of was I kind of
deserved the crown but I just didn't
decide that's not going to be my
identity for the rest of my life it's
just going to be something I went
through it was these things these things
can Define you
um or or they they these things that
happened to us in our lives these things
sometimes we cause them sometimes we
don't but this crap that we all walk
through from time to time in our lives
uh you know don't let it be like who are
you oh I'm a guy that got divorced no
you're not you're just a guy yeah
and you got divorced I mean you're not a
you know you're not defined by this
process so or this I'm not I'm not
defined by bankruptcy it's just one of
the things that happened in my life
that's right and you're not a guy who is
destined to be poor because his parents
were no or I'll bankruptcy or whatever
you know all that kind of stuff so yeah
you're fine you're fine Hang on we're
gonna send you a copy of Ken's book uh
paycheck to purpose we're also going to
sign you up for his assessment take that
it'll help you assess what your
strengths are and maybe where are some
directions you can go but dude go plug
into some marketing and social media
positions some digital marketing
positions are all over Dallas people are
hiring like crazy and uh you should be
able to jump into something pretty quick
plus like you know 80 hours of ubereats
or you know you can't do a reaching on
the car but whatever I mean go go find
something to do where you're working
your tail end off and pile you up five
or ten thousand bucks to get the wolf
away from the door this is the Ramsay
show
foreign
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
well folks we hope that the information
you get here the inspiration you get
here is helpful to you that's why we've
been doing this show for 30 something
years and it has proven to be helpful to
millions of people and if it has you
could um you could help us
we'd appreciate it if you're listening
on YouTube or
one of the podcast platforms Spotify
Apple whatever you can subscribe that
helps the algorithms and helps spread
the word about the show uh you can share
the show meaning link it to some to
whatever you're listening and send it
out and you could even just say hey I
listened to it on this talk radio
station and share with your friends tell
people about us we would appreciate that
that's very very helpful you are our
number one promotional outlet and so
word of mouth is how this show has grown
it's how it's prospered it's how it's
survived and so if uh if you want to be
of help to us that's what you're doing
you could leave a review in places where
you can and as long as it's a five star
review we really don't need the other
ones but thank you
Coleman the uh
the layoffs are out there we had this
huge
shortage of Labor kind of still do oh
yeah absolutely still do it's a weird
stagflation economy that we're in really
a shortage of Labor and yet a recession
is um blooming yep appears to be being
predicted the FED had asked for this
they're trying to cause it and I think
they're pulling it off so a lot of large
publicly traded companies are laying
people off last Monday night the night
before Thanksgiving uh United Furniture
makes Lane Furniture uh send an email to
all 2 700 workers at their Mississippi
plant and they went home on Monday from
work and got an email yeah or a text
saying they'll come back tomorrow most
woke up in the morning the email went
out late at night and woke up the next
morning you're done don't even come in
yeah Asurion here in Nashville has laid
off a couple thousand layoffs a couple
thousand people different times uh
Facebook has announced that the
company's gonna be laying off 11 000
employees 13 of its Workforce of course
musk laid off half of Twitter
for whatever reason uh 3 700 jobs there
Amazon laid off 10 000 workers marking
the largest job Cuts in the company's
history Rideshare company Lyft laid off
13 of its staff 700 workers earlier this
month fintech stripe announced it would
lay off 14 of its Workforce 1100
employees online real estate broker
Redfin laid off 862 workers about 13 of
his Workforce Salesforce the enterprise
software company uh cut hundreds of
workers last week and the company stock
has dropped about 38 percent in value
layoffs they are out there they are but
it is important to hear because you just
heard Dave walk through a list and the
media is playing this up big time
because it makes you click but you need
to understand something what is common
among that list and among the other
large layoffs over the last 90 days is
anticipation these companies are laying
people off in anticipation of a
recession most of these companies are
publicly held companies so they are
thinking about their stock price it's a
different game than small business in
America so what they will do is they
will hire up and staff up so you hear
Amazon laying off tens of thousands of
workers why let's just translate that
okay
public these publicly traded companies
are buttholes
okay because here's what they're doing
all right let me tell you why Salesforce
in their press release Salesforce said
they laid these people off to increase
profits that's exactly right it's about
the stock price simply increase in
profits and so I mean
I mean so you didn't need them when you
hired them
you they weren't going to make you money
when you hired them
oh no no they were gonna make us money
but one way to increase profits is to
slash the payroll line on the p l
temporarily and it temporarily makes us
look like we're more profitable although
there's not people to do the work that
causes us to be more profitable later
that's correct so we rehired later and
so it's Corporate America being
buttholes all they're doing is they're
they're creating Pro false profit no kid
no pun intended I like that false
prophet profit that didn't come from
generating revenues and doing a better
job profit that came from cutting and
expense that you actually needed and
Investments that you actually needed in
order to appear to be more profitable
that's right and they do that on the
backs of you in America and some of you
uh you're really having the great regret
because some of you left a job with a
company that actually was a pretty good
company to make
15 or 20 more thousand dollars over a
publicly traded jerk wad bill that's
right and they told you you could work
from home and guess who got guess who
got laid off first at all these
companies all the all the research we're
seeing coming in the the number one the
two types of people that got laid off
the last one's hired and the ones that
are working from home that's correct
that's exactly right the data says that
that's not our opinion that's what the
data says and the reason you're out of
sight you're out of mind and Dave you're
absolutely right out of your mind that's
right you look at Amazon for instance so
Amazon it came out early this year an
internal Memo from one of their
Executives they were worried about being
able to actually hire people in multiple
cities of the US because they had burned
through available workers they treat
people like Commodities and Dave's
exactly right the minute that a
recession might be looming what do they
do it's about the almighty dollar and
the stock price and we're not against
capitalism we love it and I'm all for
profit but the fact of the matter is
Dave you're exactly right they begin to
just diminish people and they go all
right you are just a number on a
spreadsheet we don't care about you it
was all about the stock price it's all
about profit so when consumers I
announced our 1100 people last week that
our profits are down this year because
our costs are up
and as a result we are laying off
precisely no one
because we wouldn't have freaking hired
you in the first place if we didn't need
you
and I'm not going to put more money in
my pocket as the owner
and increase my profits by dumping you
in the street at the first sign of a
black cloud because I'm like a human and
I like other humans and treat them like
people not like robots that can be
thrown in the ditch the first time
something comes up that's right and
that's how small business operates by
and large you don't hear small
businesses going oh we're going to lay
people off so I can make more profit
yeah
people that own small businesses don't
do that and as a matter of fact right
now Dave small businesses are looking to
hire they can't find people to hire it's
the exact difference they're trying to
grow their business and Amazon and the
big public companies are trying to just
grow their stock price yeah big
difference so Corporate America has
always and and this is not against
capitalism by Corporate America I mean
big companies with no heart no soul
and and some big companies have a heart
and soul some little companies don't
have a heart so but I'm talking when I'm
when I say Corporate America I mean
these companies that treat people they
treat the customer
like a unit of Revenue they treat so you
know you're a number when you're a
customer of Bank of America Bank of
America sucks
if you're a customer Bank of America you
know they couldn't care less whether you
live or die you are a number
that's all they care about as a customer
you're a unit of Revenue and by the way
if you work there you're a unit of
production and there's no Humanity in a
company like that none whatsoever now
there's again it's not based solely on
size but you guys know what I'm talking
about and so what this is is a warning
on behalf of the Ken Coleman movement
to get a job get a career make a move if
you want to make a move uh for more
money if you want to that's great I got
no issue with that for a better
opportunity for an area that's where you
are functioning in your sweet spot in
your purpose yeah but don't be going
solely based on money I'm gonna hold my
nose and move over to some company that
has a value system that I can't stand
they're so woke I can't sleep that's
right and I don't want to be around
these people and you're going to run
over there and jump in the middle of
that septic tank and hold your nose and
hope you don't get screwed well of
course you're going to get screwed
that's exactly right here's what happens
the paycheck and the promotion wear off
when you the person know that you're in
the wrong pool you just know it's not
right it will eat away at you your soul
will slowly slip out of your body where
you work matters yeah and you so yes go
make more money yes get into something
that is your purpose but don't have an
existential crisis because during covert
you suddenly decided someday you're
going to die no kidding
and so now I have to go do I have to
quickly I have to go I have to go I have
to go make more money I'm burnt out hey
hey hey hey hey hey hey I'm gonna work
from home part-time and get paid for
full time hey hey you're gonna be the
first one in the ditch baby and that's
what's happening right now this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
all right after ranting about layoffs by
Corporate America they go in the
commercial break and Coleman tells me
this story The curled both the hairs
that I have left
tell me about it oh I'm sorry it was a
setup okay so that was an underhand
pitch yeah yeah I thought God's like
swing I thought you were going yeah here
we go so
so a guy uh who is the CEO at the time
he's since been relieved of his duties
thankfully of a company called
better.com and here's the irony that's
the name of the company he laid off
several thousand people
from his kitchen over Zoom no previous
warning no none of their managers
talking to them company-wide zoom and he
decided to lay off that many people and
then gave him instructions hey we'll be
in touch your leader we'll be in touch
with you soon to explain the terms of
you leaving but he just dropped it on
him in his kitchen via zoom and what was
the best part of it Dave is about
halfway through he got choked up because
it was so difficult to do
and I just wanted your take on that
and I'm trying not to question his
sincerity uh but but to do it without
the question is sincerity but sincerity
but you can question his character yeah
I mean this is not a guy I mean it
suddenly occurred to him that he just
dumped thousands of people in the street
halfway through the call I mean exactly
dude you were never a leader in the
first place you shouldn't have been in
that seat you're not qualified that's
not even real communication Dave that's
just uh that's what's called uh
oh cowardice that's what you call it
right oh yeah okay I'm a freaking coward
yeah it's like he was ripping the
Band-Aid off for him yeah not for them
exactly so here's the thing
do sometimes companies reach a point
that they are not profitable or are
approaching that and have to as a
mathematical necessity let people go
yeah we were facing that potentially
during covet we didn't know what we were
going to have I mean we had and we had
tens of millions of dollars of Revenue
in certain areas like for instance doing
Live Events remember when you stopped
doing that suddenly remember when I
canceled a cruise in the middle of March
of 2020 yeah that was handy uh so when
the revenue just evaporates
and there's no money
then you can't pay people then you've
got to lay them off but then and but but
there's a couple things that go with
that uh this is not this is not laying
people off just to increase your profits
which is about as
Corporate America as it gets okay so
there's a couple things that go with
this these problems number one
the Factory in Mississippi laying off
2700 the the duper from better give me a
break uh laying people off from Zoom
from his kitchen table suddenly with no
warning those two had shared one thing
in common they knew they were in trouble
oh a long time before they laid those
people off that's correct so you owe
your team
information that's accurate yeah
well they might leave
dumb butt you're getting ready to lay
them off okay I mean seriously of course
they might leave because
you're announcing that the ship is
taking on water we think we can stay
afloat but uh we got a leak over here
and you go ahead and tell these guys
it's like
months before because you know it months
before yeah you know what's going on and
so number one lots and lots and lots of
clear
open authentic communication early and
often this is what you do if you're a
real leader in a company regardless of
the size of the company and and then the
second thing
is you do not lay people off in order to
line your own pockets
these are people that have lives they
have kids and dogs and
husbands and wives and college funds and
I mean you don't build your personal
fortune on the backs of laying people
off that trusted you by coming to work
for you
that's morally wrong that's right okay
that's just that's wrong and so you know
it's not it's not a legal issue at all
but a you need to give them notice lots
and lots of open communication lots of
notice B do sometimes then you actually
have to do this because it's an
arithmetic thing yeah yeah that's right
sometimes you have to and then uh you
should
feel it yeah going through a zoom call
that's right it's dignity it's the
difference between I'm on a zoom and I
had no warning and all of a sudden bam
I'm not sitting there with my leader
able to process information and ask
questions I've just been hit right in
the forehead and there's nothing I can
do about it
all right changing the subject Julianne
is with us in Santa Rose California hi
Julianne how are you
well hello Dave and Ken thanks so much
for taking my call your your show is a
real blessing thank you how can we help
so so I am 63 years old and pardon me
I've got I make about 64 000 a year
um I've got eighteen thousand dollars in
credit card debt I'm looking to retire
at 68.
um Ken I've listened to you talk about
that have a passion for what you do and
well I don't think I'm in that group but
I do work in a government position and I
will be getting a pension so that is why
I'm there I'm looking like I said I'm
looking to retire at 68.
um and Mike my question is I just and I
have about a hundred thousand dollars in
Combined 401k and the sarsap and when I
retire my the two pensions I'll get plus
my social security from a higher paying
job before will equals pretty much what
I'm making now but you qualify for those
pensions now don't you
uh no I don't the one pension was with a
law firm and I have to wait till I'm 65
to to get that okay what about the other
the other one I don't quite have five
years in yet so no I can't get that
either if I stop at five uh in within
the next six months or so but that will
be a lot less than if I wait another
five years which is why I was gonna
retire at 68 then that'll make me
eligible for Social Security as well I
my social security is at 66 to 10 months
but I figure 68 will put 10 years in at
my government job and then I would use
the money as I need
um and the hundred thousand in the
combined 401k and starstep I live in
affordable housing so I have no property
or anything what's your question
my question is is um
how do I leverage getting the most out
of my situation
be more specific what do you mean what
are you trying to Leverage
um I'm trying to
um have a better standard of living
my retire I because before I retire I to
pay off the 18 000 in credit card I
don't know how I'm going to do that and
then I also I have a beater van from
when my mom days of course I don't have
that anymore and so I was looking to get
one more car for like my forever car and
I don't know how I'm going to make all
that happen sure you do yeah five years
I'm sure you do well that's why you
called Dave's going to help you but I'm
going to give you the formula though so
you can get your head right number one
you need to you need to pay off your
debt and you might need to supplement
your income right now to make that
happen faster and then you're going to
be fine you got to pay off this debt
and I I work I was thinking about that
thank you and I work full time
um and I don't know how I I I've
listened to the side over time you work
40 hours overtime is your answer they
are they full-time is 80.
uh no we're 40 hours a week I know
that's eight hours five days a week and
they don't pay overtime they will not
authorize it I know so go get a job
working doing something else in addition
to this
work more
okay that's my only option yeah
oh you have another option continue to
stay broke
no it's it's depressing it really is and
I don't want to be depressed yeah so I
don't I don't know how I would work in
addition because I work eight to five
five days a week and like I said I'm 63
I'm not 23 but so am I so
you're not an invalid
I work all the time I mean I'm 63. I you
know 16 hour days if I need to I'm
entirely possible I don't like doing it
either but I mean there's sometimes I
have to get crap done and so you got 18
000 worth of debt in a junkie van you
got to fix these things and you're gonna
need more money you're going to tighten
the budget that you've got
and you're gonna have to increase your
income
and uh
you need financial peace we've got the
process for you walk it through you're
discouraged you need to get determined
this is not a an unsolvable situation we
have the steps yeah hang on we'll give
you a copy of the book Total Money
Makeover and show you exactly what to do
but you're gonna have to increase your
income and you're gonna have to out
decrease your outgo so stuff you're
spending money on while you're sitting
around other than your 40 hours of work
uh you're not gonna be able to spend
money on that anymore because you're not
gonna be sitting around anymore there
you go this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today hey we have a blast giving away a
ton of cash in the Ramsey Christmas Cash
giveaway this month the giveaway ends
very soon you need to enter now if you
want a chance to win now we've been
giving away 500 a week and right now you
can enter every day to increase your
chances to win the grand prize which is
five thousand dollars which you're gonna
be giving away in just a few days
there's no purchase necessary you got to
be 18 years or older older go to
ramseysolutions.com while you're there
check out the kids sale get prices as
low as ten dollars on stuff like the
teen entrepreneur toolbox The Graduate
survival guide questions for humans
conversation cards lots and lots and
lots of our books are ten dollars like
almost all of them uh we are having the
opposite of inflation at the Ramsay
website so uh no one told our marketing
team that there's inflationary economy
so and apparently we are going to just
sell the crap out of stuff at a deal so
Ramsey cash giveaway and the sale both
end very soon do not wait go to
ramseysolutions.com Victoria is with us
in Tampa Florida hi Victoria welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hi Dave hi Kim thanks for taking my call
sure what's up
um so my husband and I need some advice
so we don't make a stupid decision here
um so my husband and I have a small town
home our monthly payment is so cheap and
it's under a thousand dollars which is
crazy for Tampa Florida right now
um our town home is super basic it's a
two bedroom two and a half back no
garage and our plan was to pay it off
um and we're so close to it um we have
about fifty thousand dollars in savings
um and we owe about 112 000 in our homes
um if we put that money towards our home
we would owe about sixty thousand
dollars and we could easily tackle that
in less than two years
um the thing is though we had a baby a
few months ago and I work hybrid our
home feels too tight and I am afraid I
will not be able to buy another home if
the price goes higher right now
um so we could upgrade to a three
bedroom
in a garage and by selling our home
including all of our savings and
whatever money we make from this home
um towards this other option we have we
we would potentially put down 50 uh
percent
and our monthly payment would be about
300 more than what we pay right now in
our current home now my question is in
what circumstance it's okay to not pay
off your home at this point is it better
to just upgrade or
just like suck it up and stick around so
Victoria I've got a question I've got a
question before Dave answers the money
piece uh what makes the house feel
cramped with a newborn and I want you to
be specific and I'm not picking on you I
want you to really tell me what makes it
feel cramped they're not that big yes so
I hope well it is a two bedroom uh in um
two and a half baths so
um right now in order for me to not quit
my job my mom will be with us to help
with the baby for about a year
um so she's she's still going to stay
with us for a few more months
um yeah I feel like okay now you got me
on that one I didn't see that one coming
one room for her baby to sing with us
yeah uh maybe the same with those in the
bedrooms
um it's it's fine right now and we don't
have a garage so literally like we walk
into the house I am literally here's the
answer here's the answer here's what
you're facing Victoria okay
at the end of your story
when you get to retirement you want to
have had a paid for house for many years
before you get there
and as a result of not having a house
payment a huge pile of money
okay that's that's that's where that's
what we're aiming at we're agreed on
that okay now the question is how do we
have a life
that's reasonable
and under control and still accomplish
having paid off the house early
and creating a big pile of money
in your 40s 50s and 60s right how old
are you
I'm 31. my husband okay so if you'd go
and move up in house it's not an evil
thing you're not doing anything wrong we
tell you not to take out a mortgage more
than a fourth of your take-home pay
household take-home pay
on a 15-year fixed and so if you sell
your home and you take the 50 000 and
you put enough down and the mortgage
that you take out meets those guidelines
you're perfectly fine now why do we tell
you those guidelines because we want you
to pay it off for your sake
okay but but it's okay to move up in
property and at your age with the idea
that we're going to turn around and
start paying it off as fast as we can
because the faster we get it paid off
the wealthier we're going to be
right so it's not like you need Dave's
permission to get a bigger house
anything to do with me
it's got to do with you need your give
yourself permission to get a bigger
house which is going to slow down your
wealth building a little bit because now
you've got a bigger mortgage to get paid
off before you get rich right
right but you're trading that for a
little better quality of life three
bedrooms and a garage and some stuff
like that and a place to Camp mom for a
little while she's probably not going to
be there forever though kid grows up
things move on right but um but but
still it's okay to move out of a two
bedroom no garage townhouse
in Tampa Florida you can probably afford
to make that move up with the large
equity in the down payment and all that
kind of stuff you're putting together
you're probably fine to do that but you
know it the the thing you don't want to
do is get in the mindset of most
Americans which is I'm just going to buy
whatever I want whenever I want
I'm gonna spend like I'm in Congress and
then I'm going to retire broke and hope
the government which is well known for
its ability to handle money will take
care of me
and see just don't don't drop over on
that side of the bucket because that's
where people drown right that's where
you get killed so you know the fact that
you're fretting about this is a very is
a positive because it makes you realize
you're not going to do it over and over
and over again because some people the
way they celebrate
um getting a raise is they go get a
bigger car payment it's what most people
are doing
you know and that's not you know so what
am I going to go further in debt well
that's dumber than crud
because it takes you exactly the wrong
direction now in her case she's not
doing that that's not what's going on so
I think you're perfectly fine to make
that move but you do whatever you want
as long as you're as long as you're
couching it in the concept of I want to
get my house paid off because if I get
my house paid off the wealthier I'm
going to be and the more generous I can
be and the more I can change my family
tree and those things are all tied
together mathematically it's arithmetic
Hatton is where this Hatton is in
Oklahoma City hi Hatton what's up
I'm doing well Dave how are you better
than I deserve how can we help
okay so I am 24 years old I'm currently
living in Southwestern Oklahoma and I
have gotten myself into some debt I had
put
um some debt on a credit card and I'd
run the amount up pretty highly and I
decided to take out an unsecured loan
with a local bank to get a lower
interest rate and I was looking to see
how you would be able to advise me to
pay this debt off as as quickly as
possible so you have the credit card
debt or the personal loan now
um I took the loan out at the uh okay so
how much do you owe on the purse
uh
uh seventy two hundred and fifty dollars
did you chop up the stupid butt credit
card
I had a plastic to me at my uh future uh
mother-in-law's house a couple of weeks
ago phenomenal that's a good place to
celebrate that makes her smile
good yes you might be able to take care
of my daughter because you're getting
the scissors across the card good all
right good good good good good 7 200
bucks what do you make
uh this next year I could be making
anywhere between 39 and 41 000 a year
before taxes well you do
I work as a minister good for you okay
you need an extra job my dad was a
pastor and my my brother and I he put us
in a small Christian School we needed
more money and he was limited because he
was a pastor and he went and worked on a
construction crew for three months
you got to do that 7 200 is nothing for
a 24 year old who wants to work
all right yeah go make two thousand
bucks a month for three or four months
and you'll be done
but I mean you'll be tired you'll be
tired and cold
but you can do that when you're 24. it's
okay you can do it when you're 64. it's
okay
um you know you don't
used to work for a guy who said you know
hard work won't kill you right before
you die you pass out
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
Ramsay Network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show where that is dumb
Cassius king and the paid off Home
Mortgage has taken the place of the BMW
as the status symbol of choice
we help people
build wealth
do work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships this is the Ramsay
Show Ken Coleman is my co-host today
host of the Ken Coleman show
and author of the number one
best-selling book
from paycheck to purpose our phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five Merry Christmas
America we're glad you're with us Zach
is with us in Huntsville hi Zach what's
up
yeah not much I'm
uh the blanket questions I'm trying to
figure out if it's worth staying at a
lease purchase trucking company as an
employer or when I should decide to move
on to something else
um
uh details for why I I took this job to
begin with a a number of truckers
suggested I do this because overall it
does double my income in a normal Market
even after all the payments and stuff
like that I'm allowed to walk away at
any time so I'm not obligated to like
pay a large balloon payment at the end
of the lease or in order to get away
from it or anything like a car lease I
can walk away at any time if they fire
me I don't owe anything on the truck etc
etc
okay so you're an over you're a truck
driver
and the deal with this employer is you
lease your truck
from them
with no obligation to continue leasing
it
and then they give you loads
yeah yeah pretty much it I at least as a
condition of working here I gotta lease
the truck uh I don't have uh
try to get through this one upstairs
um
to work here I lease the truck yeah at
the end of the lease I can pay for it
pay it off or I can save up money I can
come in with my own truck as long as it
meets their specifications and my own
trailer paid off and I can still work
for them that's the goal I was aiming
for because in a normal Market it does
actually pay double what I normally make
as a company driver and I had that for
the first few paychecks but the Freight
Market is just tanking right now it's
hard to find anything that pays more
than
250 a mile in the networks that we
operate under and from other truck
drivers I hear it's
pretty well that way across the board so
I've
not been able to make that not by the
fault of the company but the markets
just tanked so when you lease the truck
you're paying a lease payment are you
also responsible for insurance and
maintenance and fuel
um uh insurance and stuff yes the fuel
they got two programs they
got an 80 20 program where I'm in charge
of fuel and tolls if I'm on that or they
got a 50 50 program where they will pay
for the fuel and the tolls and then I
just got the truck payment trailer
payment and the uh
uh insurance and just a couple other uh
small charges that really uh which
technically those last few they don't go
away even if I own my truck well right
here's the deal twice in this phone call
you've mentioned in a normal market then
you explained what's actually happening
with the market the Market's changed and
I think you have to change and the good
news is it doesn't sound like there's a
penalty for you to change
the the hang up I have is I've had this
goal for a long time I'm
and it changed on me so quickly I'm not
sure what you had what you had what goal
the goal to be an owner operator
yeah to own the truck and be under my
own authority so I have more leverage
because like if I work at a company
typically it's two to three weeks out
and then you get a day off of for home
time for every day that you're out yeah
okay
is this a storm that you need to weather
and can you weather it or is this a
function of the Mountaintop is still the
same it's still the same goal but I got
to climb the mountain a different way
weather patterns come in and I got to
change course it's either a or b what's
the situation
I'm thinking that it's a storm that I
might have to weather I'm
okay what do you mean what are you
making after all all your payments
coming out of your pocket what are you
walking away with net right now
I uh net I've been making a thousand to
fifteen hundred a week well you can make
that drive for somebody else that's a
fact you can make that driving a local
route for a larger company
50 Grand a year
yeah roughly and uh that's the reason I
mentioned the normal Market I have
testimony from drivers that work for
this exact same company before the
market started going down they were
emitting 3 000 to a few of them were
netting 5000 a week after everything was
said and done right but it's changed so
you have to sit back and say is this
company this particular situation the
only way for me to get to my ultimate
goal and the answer is it's not the only
way so a question
um how old are you
uh 29. and you're married kids
uh unfortunately divorced and no kids
okay all right so what would I do if I
woke up in your shoes based on the
information you've given me if I
understand the situation and I may not
okay
um but I've worked with uh people
driving truck for years and doing what I
do and we're on Sirius XM so a thousand
years ago we started having a huge
trucker following to this show so I
learned a little bit about the business
just because I've been around the people
doing it doing the hard work that you're
doing
um so anyway what I would do is I would
go to work for someone on a regular
employment position right now and I'd
work like a crazy person live on nothing
and pile up cash like crazy if the
market turns you can come back to this
model
three years from now if if you can make
three times as much three years from now
but today you're not making even what
you can make for somebody else
okay and there's and if you can jump out
you can jump back in
so jump out go get a job make it and go
you know go do three weeks and and just
pile up money man
and towards buying a truck
and then get you a good used truck and
if it doesn't meet their specs well who
gives a crap all you gotta do is get the
stuff there and you go book your own
loads
get a broker and book your own loads and
um so I know lots of guys that have
saved up their first 20 25 000 bucks get
their tractor and they pull other
people's trailers and then they finally
get them a trailer and then they move up
from a twenty five thousand dollar
thirty thousand dollar tractor up into a
you know like an 80 and and then because
you can as you know you can spend a
freaking half million dollars there's no
Roi on that at all
except think you're thinking you're
pretty at a stoplight it's as dumb as
driving a car that does that
uh so you don't want to do that you want
to do the truck that gets the job done
and doesn't leave you broken on the side
of the road and isn't eaten fuel like it
so yeah I'm I'm gonna save up money get
my first truck that's what I'm gonna do
and what's the fastest way to do that
right now it's working for somebody else
that's right so Zach what we're seeing
is we're not changing the dream we're
changing the course to get to the dream
yeah that's all we're just gonna change
if you can triple your income three
years from now by coming back to this
model jump back and you're not quite got
your money saved up to buy a truck you
didn't do it but the idea that that you
have to provide a truck that meets their
specs later on
uh that sounds like
um maybe you need to have a wider net
for the truck that you're driving than
this one company who's going to dictate
what you drive
I don't think I'm playing that game you
should decide what you're gonna drive
based on what makes good business sense
and what you can pay cash for
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more births
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today it is Christmas time and with the
new year coming out we've got the new
increase your income bundle Ken yeah
this is fun Dave so what if you could
get paid to do work that you're really
good at and that you enjoy and this
bundle is going to include my new book
the number one bestseller from paycheck
to purpose our very popular get clear
career assessment and then the get hired
digital course including the resume
templates and you get all of this for
only 49.99 that's 50 off I didn't
approve that Dave I didn't approve that
steep of a discount that's ridiculous
that's an unbelievable discount
and speaking of increasing your income
the Ramsey Christmas Cash giveaway ends
soon so make sure you folks go to
ramseysolutions.com giveaway and enter
every day to increase your chances to
win the five thousand dollar grand prize
Dave is like the real life
Santa Claus every year we give away a
lot of money by the way no purchase
necessary and you do have to be 18 or
older to win that's ramseysolutions.com
giveaway so head to rangesolutions.com
there's all kinds of goodies there oh
all kinds of Bargains Jeff is with us
Jeff's in Springfield Missouri hi Jeff
how are you
I'm doing all right thanks for taking my
call Dave sure what's up I I over the
last five years I took a
um I lost my job and took a pay cut of
about fifty thousand dollars
um I've sense in the last year I brought
my income back to where I was before
this happened but over the last five
years
I've also had a failing business and I
built up quite a bit of credit card debt
um 110 000 my wife and I we make about a
hundred and fifteen thousand dollars a
year but we have a hundred and ten
thousand dollars in credit card debt
between the business and ourselves and
we're strapped I and would
contemplating bankruptcy looking at all
of our options or doing what we can do
with
your every dollar plan on the budget
things like that but we've quite frankly
just started that and I'm just looking
for some older advice
about 52 years old what kind of business
was it it's been a rough
it was a houseworking business
you got any of them left
um in the middle of one right now but
it's I mean it's out of all the houses
we've done this has been the worst house
and
it's eating Us Alive
you'll make a profit on it when you flip
it
Maybe
a little I mean what do you owe on it I
can we owe about 115 and it's probably
worth 140 to 150. yeah when's it going
on the market
hopefully in the next week or so good
what do you owe in your home
I owe three hundred thousand dollars
that's worth five hundred thousand
dollars we've built it about 18 years
ago and have a lot of Sweat Equity in it
okay so of the 115 000 income you told
us is that your wife I'm assuming or do
you have an egg or is this I said he got
a new good job okay right yeah no I've
got a my job is is really good
um pays well my wife
works and does does well also for this
area so over overall flipping houses you
have lost when all the smoke cleared 110
000.
between that and then my job my salary I
mean we were living on credit cards for
a while
okay all right so but the bottom line
was you the overall business model of
flipping houses you lost money on it
and mainly that's been in the last two
years since covet okay and this this
house has really been a disaster yeah
okay all right
so and how old did you say you were
again 52 you said yeah okay yeah
um
the good news is you're not bankrupt the
bad news is
um
you're you're scared and you're beat up
absolutely
and when we're scared and when we're
beat up
uh we tend to make
uh we have more of a tendency to make
bad decisions because we're kind of in a
fog you're in the forest can't see the
trees kind of thing been there myself I
know how it feels it's it's hard to
think clear because everything's just
overwhelming you this idea of just
surviving
does that sound familiar
absolutely yeah
okay
so this is going to
um
hurt your feelings and hurt your wife's
feelings even more
but uh you can pay the credit card debt
you just gotta sell your house
I don't understand that and here's the
bad news I don't know the rule in
Missouri but in every state except Texas
and Florida you can't keep this much
equity in bankruptcy
because what happens is they they have a
homestead exemption when you file
Chapter 7 bankruptcy there's a homestead
exemption which is the amount of your
Equity that you get to keep
and anything above that that's
substantial they're going to force the
sale of the house to pay your creditors
so you might as well pay them
so are you behind on the credit cards
no we are current we've called them and
got reduced monthly payments and good
we've canceled all the credit cards good
um so what I would do having been
through what you're going through except
with zeros on the end and I was 28 I
wasn't 52 but I still remember being so
freaking scared I couldn't breathe
what I would do if I were you is I would
fight like a wild man to not have to
sell my house
let's pre let's pretend you pay a bunch
of credit cards late over the next
three years
and it messes up your credit but you
become debt free except the house
I would do that
and by the way 115 000 income thirty
thousand a year you can do for three
years forty thousand a year for three
years you can do it on 115 000 income
you got no life but you get to keep your
house no life during that three years
and you're probably gonna be working
extra doing something else well that's
and you're going to be selling
everything you can get your hands on
including this junky butt house you're
getting ready to get rid of
Jeff how much time ballpark are you
spending per week on this house it's
almost gone yeah
how many hours beyond your work are you
spending on this flip house
probably 25 hours a week all right so
today's Point here I'm trying to give
you some hope I agree with Dave I I get
rid of that house quickly as possible
and now we're done with that and now
that 25 hours I've been spinning on that
sinkhole I'm gonna spend the 25 hours
because you're pretty handy guy you
could pick up some really nice pain work
with your skills true or false
um yes the answer is true inside hustles
I know my point is listen you either do
that or you sell your house yeah and I'd
keep the house yeah work the extra 25
hours and pay that hustle my way through
this and pay 40 or 50 000 a year on this
debt and be done with it in two two and
a half years that's my plan
okay
all right that's what I how I'd get
after that and and so the good so here's
the thing
we just said there's two possible paths
that's not bankrupt and by the way
bankrupt won't work you're going to lose
your house
in bankruptcy they're going to take it
and pay your creditors because you don't
you have so much Equity unless I'm wrong
I don't know again off the top of my
head you could ask what home Google you
can do it as soon as you get off I could
do it live if I had to run Google but
Google Google what the home homestead
exemption for Missouri is but I'm
betting you that it's you know probably
10 20 30 grand something like that and
you got three you got a 200 Grand
it's it's 15 and I would have to go
chapter 13. yeah well you're not chapter
13 is you chapter 13 is a payment plan
and you pay the creditors
I know and so we'll just pale you got
this Jeff even if you pay them late
chapter 13 destroys your credit paying
them late destroys your credit whoopee
destroy your credit who gives a crap
we're talking about bankruptcy here
talking about you keeping your house
we're talking about you turning the
corner on this chat putting this chapter
of your life that sucks in the rear view
mirror
so me the path I'm taking I'm gonna work
like a maniac for the next three years
I'm gonna get rid of this stupid house
in the next 30 days even if I break even
on it so I can get my life back and then
I'm gonna tear into these credit cards
working the death snowball smallest to
largest and you're not bankrupt you just
got a sucky two and a half years coming
up to put this crap in the rear of your
mirror and you can do it hang on we're
going to sign you up for Financial Peace
University we're going to pay for it and
Jeff been where you are man I know how
it feels to be scared I can hear it in
your voice you call me anytime we'll
help you we'll encourage you we'll yell
at you we'll cheer for you whatever it
takes to keep you moving man this is the
Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
Jordan is in Greenville South Carolina
hi Jordan welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi
um I owe eleven thousand dollars on a
car that doesn't run and I can't afford
to fix it and I really don't know what
to do
ouch
why can't you afford to fix it
um I just don't have the money
all right follow-up question
why don't you have any money
well I am working
um it's just a car that I got back in
high school and my parents were getting
me in the car but
um
I'm having to pay for it and
um How much would it cost to fix
ten thousand dollars who said
um we've got lots of estimates around my
area and it's into multiple body shops
um oh so you got you got in a wreck and
didn't have insurance
no um
basically they've told me the make and
model of my car is
is not working anymore like they put a
bad piston in it and you don't go to a
body shop
that would be a mechanic not a body shop
all kinds of mechanics Than People okay
so uh what do you get what do you make a
year
um monthly about 1500 to 1800 what do
you do
I'm an interior designer and a chef at a
fine dining restaurant
no you're a sous chef
yeah she's a sous chef yes chefs don't
make 1800. okay
um at fine dining anyway
um
so what are you 23
thank you
I'm sorry
22 22. okay good guess Dave like you've
done this before okay uh
and you have a roommate
or you live at home
um I live at home
so you don't have overhead
and you bring in no I don't you bring in
1800 a month where does that money go
um I've been paying off my car with it
um saving it
I have about uh 4 500 saved up I'm I
just recently signed up for the
Financial Peace University and um I'm on
baby step two good for you so I still
owe eleven thousand I got yeah and
that's is that your only debt is your
car
um I have 1 000 in medical bills okay
good good
okay
and you're working a lot
yes and not making any money
no the life of a chef a sous chef okay
yeah and an assistant yeah yeah
um are you putting in more than 40 hours
um
I'm not I'm not sure because how are you
getting to work
um I'm borrowing my mom's car right now
because her and my stepdad work out the
same job okay
well it sounds like you've got a
wonderful support system
you've got a place to live
while you fight your way through this
and you've just got a a horrible car
situation you're being very smart you're
taking a class on how to handle money
very smart uh you've saved up forty five
hundred dollars very smart uh so the
weak spot in your story me looking in
from the outside is your income
you don't make any money
yeah
so
um your is your dream to be a fine
dining chef
no I went to school for interior design
and when I got out of school I um
instantly went into a design company
where I
am now the designers assistant but um
and that's your day job
yes and what do you make what do you
make at that
15 an hour this is the same amount but
that is
um under the table because
I'm just her assistant like she works by
herself
okay so two different areas of your life
we've got to work on your long-term play
is you need a path for interior design
that's not fifteen dollars part-time
under the table
I just um I did get my degree in
interior design okay great so you so
you're completely underpaid and
underemployed there and in addition to
that your other job is an underpaid job
as well just by the nature of what it is
uh and so uh what we've got to do is
we've got to get your day job cooking
better
better much better interior design day
job and a much better night job and Sous
Chef's not it because you need three
four thousand dollars a month coming in
and you can solve this problem real
quick
yeah but you're you're starving to death
yes so let's let's work on those two
sides of your career the go get a much
better part-time job than sous chef Sous
Chef's not your dream anyway it's hard
freaking work it's hot back there
yeah I mean it that's some of the
hardest thankless jobs the chef gets all
the credit and you do all the work
uh and most Sous chefs are Chef wannabes
and they're it's their dream to be a big
time Chef you don't even want to do that
and you're you say and so with that in
mind that job sucks completely passion
for it I know but you need to you need
to go do something where you make some
money kiddo that's right now raise your
sights in the interior design side of
things you've got a degree you've got
some experience you're very creative as
a sous chef all that creativity is what
you love but Dave's right you've got to
say I if I've got to go work for a
construction company and and and Stage
rooms I'm gonna do that for a season
well there's nothing wrong with that
that's good money doing it that's right
why because we want to get out of this
financial hole the good news is you're
off and running on the baby steps so
glad you're doing that but we're going
to make the move right now to get stable
in the now and you're not in any way uh
forfeiting your dream of interior design
so that's the key you can always get
back to that but right now we've got to
get more money coming in that's going to
change everything for you yeah I want
you to go pick up three jobs a new
interior design job that's a thousand
times better than the one you got and
two part-time jobs that pay big money
and I want you to work all the time
and get you three four five thousand
dollars a month coming in and all of a
sudden this car issue will evaporate
and uh by the way I'm not buying that
you owe eleven thousand dollars on a car
that needs ten thousand dollars worth of
repairs I don't either I I'm just an old
redneck that turns wrenches and so don't
believe it I just don't believe it and
uh so I I think I think there's
something else to do here you may want
to junk the car and get what you can get
for it with a little bit of work but you
probably get three or four thousand
dollars for anything that's running
and uh and then just talk to the bank
about you paying the difference and then
work your way through that and go get
you a junker car a two three four
thousand dollar card to pay cash for
then start working your debts off but
you've got to work twice as much as
you're working at much better jobs
that's the solution to your situation
and I need to hear more of a roar in
your voice you you sound really really
really uh
like you're 16.
I want you to go ah
get after it kiddo you've got some
skills and all this stuff keeps
happening to you and I want you to rise
up and go happen to this stuff you've
got some you got some stuff you can go
do this I agree you know what here's a
practical example of that that Dave's
giving you here listen get your dad or
your uncle or friends that knows some
good old boy that's been working on cars
for longer than you've been alive times
three and have him look at it let's
really dive into this thing that's
taking some action yeah you got to
happen to these things you've kind of
accepted one job accepted another enough
and you need to go get some stuff
and and that's going to put you in this
situation you need incomes what you need
bad and you need a better solution on
the car than ten thousand dollars to fix
it
you know get it get it limping get it
sold get out from under it move on the
next thing get your three thousand
dollar car to drive this is the Ramsey
Show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
your life your money your job
a lot of job questions today blinds.com
is our question of the day they have a
100 satisfaction guarantee even if you
miss measure you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free free
samples free shipping and with the new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more use the promo code Ramsay to
get the best deal today's question comes
from Jeff in Michigan I work at my dream
engineering job and I'm an expert in my
field I enjoy being on the manufacturing
side of things because I'm closer to the
product which gives me a deeper grasp
into the industry this company loves to
promote from within So within the next
couple of years it is more than likely
they will send me to the corporate
excuse me to corporate to learn from
them this scares me most of that staff
doesn't even know what our products look
like they're more about data analytics
is it a bad move to decline a great
promotion I make eighty thousand dollars
with potential to make a hundred
thousand but the new job would put me in
the hundred and twenty thousand dollar
range well Jeff I think that you need to
just walk forward and listen you're not
having to decide right now this question
is honestly too early you're
overthinking it I think he's an
engineering of course he's overthinking
it I should have seen that Dave
um you know and this is a this is a case
where you've probably heard some things
you may have seen some things but it's
still okay to if within a couple years
they send you up the line and they begin
to talk to you ask good questions what
are those things that you are concerned
about can we gain uh knowledge to verify
or clarify you know that okay what I
thought was true not a good fit for me
or you know what I got some clarity on
it and what I was thinking was not true
so this is or keep walking forward B
I see rather
um you reconfigure the way they do
things because
almost everyone listening thought oh
it's a good idea for corporate to have a
freaking clue about the real product and
the real manufacturing that's exactly
right and so maybe we reconfigure where
the engineers at the core at corporate
don't stay in the Ivory Tower should add
gum much yeah and maybe you're the guy
that opens that door and says hey guess
what I learned when I was down here we
think you people are bozos don't say it
that way that's right but you could
learn something by getting on the floor
and uh so if I take the job one of the
ways I'm going to take the job is I want
to be on the floor uh at least a day a
week at least three days a month because
I don't want to lose touch with the
product that concerns me and I think
I'll be a better engineer at corporate
if I can maintain my connection with
being with being on the floor that's
right which by the way I think every bit
of that's right I completely agree with
that position from a business
transaction standpoint and so what
you're saying is I don't be siled I
don't be stuck in the Ivory Tower and
lose touch with a real job we're trying
to do yeah and that's brilliant and I
think you could bring that to the
discussion but it's too early to worry
about it nobody even opens you the job
yeah the old phrases cross that bridge
when we get to it and I think that Dave
is making a great suggestion here on
being a part of the solution here's what
I would say very quick on fear because
this I want to apply this to everybody
right now who's got kind of a fear-based
decision that they're walking through
you just have to ask the question is
fear
protecting me if I get too close to the
edge of a cliff
and I look over and I get scared now
fear is going hey dude be careful yeah
get out get out of the interstate a
truck's coming right but if fear could
be holding me back and so let's just own
the fear specifically write it out sit
down with it is there evidence to prove
that the fear is protecting me or is the
fear lying to me and holding me back
it's a great little process to walk
through no matter what you're afraid of
so good question here's the thing Dr
deloni teaches this that
when you sense fear about something
trepidation worry right about something
anxiety about something facts are your
friends that's correct
facts what is the real fact the fact is
nobody's offered you a job yet that's a
fact the fact is you've only heard one
side of this equation Ken said go
investigate find out what it's really
like not what the Rumor Mill says
because corporate rumor murals are the
most inaccurate thing out there so what
are the facts the fact is an 18 winner
is coming at me move
you know the fact is stove's hot don't
touch it touch it what are the facts not
the feelings and we're we've spent way
too much time in the last two decades in
America talking about our feelings we
ought to deal with some facts
and then let your feelings decide from
there how you feel about the facts but
let's let's start with facts because
that changes everything that leads me to
something I want to talk to you about
you've got your finger on the pulse of
this hole freaking job market that is
the weirdest job market I have ever seen
in 50 years oh yeah I've been working 50
years uh let's start cutting grass when
I was 12 I'm 62. okay so but I mean I've
been in the workplace 40 years right and
and I've owned a business a lot of that
time of one kind or another and I've
never seen a job market this is the
weirdest dadgum job market on the one
hand we've got these immoral corporate
dupers laying people off just to run
their profits up or because they're
scared of what might happen next year
and anticipation of that they do ten
thousand people put them on the street
right there's that there's people
leaving their jobs
to go take higher pay or work from home
only to find out that they're the first
ones laid off or that they've entered
into a toxic culture of some kind or
another that's a dadgum mess and so for
ten thousand or Twenty or Thirty or
forty thousand dollars more a year that
they
you know they went and took a job and
now they regret it so there's the great
resignation followed by the great regret
you got those people you got the other
people being laid off and at the same
time we've still got a labor shortage
yes it's the most convoluted screwed up
thing I've ever seen well you got a fact
that you saw the pandemic create four
million new jobs okay and then
when the pandemic was over four million
people that had left or maybe were laid
off or retired during that time didn't
come back so that's created disparity
plus you've got seven million men that
are between the age of 25 and 55 who are
able to work and are choosing not to
work they are living off of someone
whether that be government benefits
we were talking about the other day said
they spent 2 000 hours a year on a
screen which means they're getting like
Call of Duty and they don't know what
duty is that's right they're they're
medicating themselves with the dopamine
from screens and entertainment in all of
its various forms and instead of getting
out there and getting the contribution
and the dopamine that comes from hey I
did something that mattered today so we
have a work ethic crisis we have a
shortage of Labor that's right we have a
values crisis with corporate America
dumping people on the street uh we have
people jumping ship from the you know
out of The Frying Pan Into the Fire
that's right they leave what they
thought was a bad job to get a much
better pay but at a horrible Place who
treats them like crap so I can work from
home part-time and get paid for
full-time because everybody that works
from home does not work eight hours let
me just tell you okay you sit on your
butt we know what you're doing and or
you're working two of these full-time
jobs which is straight up unethical
that's professional polygamy Dave I
coined that term the other day
professional police working two
full-time jobs and calling it work from
home yeah it's it you're cheating on
both of them
professional polygamy you get quiet
quitting I decided to come up with my
own turn but it's a real thing you're
lying to both companies it's uh it's
career infidelity that's it oh my God I
know I know okay no but so here's what's
interesting and and I want to give an
economic and a money play on this all of
that that we just in the middle of that
a person that will work hard and has
character in the middle of all that
discombobulation there's opportunity big
time oh sure of course there is well but
see now here's what's interesting but
you got to be careful not to just take
the paycheck opportunity it's not just a
paycheck I'm saying you could go find a
great company at above average pay oh
yeah and move up and and have a great
career opportunity without without
working for some bunch of dubers that's
right and
um and but people don't make the
decision exclusively on the pay change
no no you've got to look at the quality
of the leadership team the situation
yeah so it's the right rule because the
data is telling us if you're working
from home or or if you're the last one
hired you're going to be the first ones
laid off absolutely true that is
database so you are vulnerable if you
took a job doing that for more so you
left a regular job in the office 40
hours making and you make thirty five
thousand dollars a year more than you
used to make but you're working from
home uh you may be your head's the first
one on the Block and here's another fact
that remote workers may be the first to
go as they ship jobs overseas they could
pay you from home they could pay
somebody from another country from home
that's a new piece of trend become a
professional polygamy yeah
let's say that three times you're a
Baptist preacher oh my gosh I'll take an
offering watch out there we go this is
the Ramsey Show
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS of moving and storage
Studios it's the Ramsay show where that
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
Home Mortgage has taken the place of the
BMW as the status symbol of choice we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships thank you for joining us
America Merry Christmas to you Ken
Coleman Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author and host of the Ken
Coleman show is my co-host today and
Ken's show specializes in helping you
with your career your work so we're here
to help you with everything you want to
talk about today Gary's going to start
us off this hour in Connecticut hi Gary
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Dave hi Ken it's a real pleasure and
honor to talk to you guys you too sir
what's up
well
um the wife and I were struggling with
um how much we can afford to spend on a
new home we've been in our paid far home
for you know the last 30 years and
um we'd like something a little better
in the real estate market
has taken us a little bit by surprise
and so forth and
um I guess we're just wondering you know
looking for permission almost of how
much money
you know out of our portfolio could we
spend to get a place that
would suit our needs better what are you
what's your current home worth
well um I would say right around 300
000. what's the uh move up home what do
you think it'll run
well
it's you know only go up to like
100 maybe 450 but it looks like we're
gonna have to spend you know up to five
to five fifty and what's what's uh your
Investment Portfolio look like how much
money you got well
um you know uh the uh you know the the
retirement accounts have taken hit and
you know they're right around I would
say you know in the 600 000 range
and then
um and and we did move the other thing
that we're kind of
you know freaked out about is that you
know it seems like in this environment
you gotta buy a home and then go back
and sell the one that you had
um so I've got like uh
um you know in the neighborhood of like
three hundred and fifty thousand dollars
in cash type stuff that that to make
that purchase it was our idea to take
the cash in a HELOC that on this home go
out and buy a home and then
sell this one pay the HELOC he lock off
and then move on
okay do you have any other assets other
than the 600 Grand
um no just you know about General
operating and emergency stuff yeah how
old are you guys
um I'm 65 and my wife is 60. okay and so
if you had a 600 000 house
and you had five hundred thousand
dollars in Investments
is that going to be about right that's
about where you'd land wouldn't it yeah
you know I that I we'd like to keep it
you know to like a 500 or 550 000 or 50
of your net worth you're gonna be a
little over a millionaire you're a
little over a millionaire now and uh
you'll be at about a 50 of that in your
property that's about as high as I'd go
yeah
so you'd give me permission to go ahead
and do that well I don't need to give
you permission you're the millionaire
I guess so but yeah I think uh but yeah
if I were in your shoes would I do that
yeah I probably would
okay and here's the thing I've got a
feeling you guys live fairly frugally so
that the five or six hundred thousand
that's in Investments is probably just
going to continue to grow you're not
going to mess with it right
no the in in the wife works and she's
got a good job I I gave up work
um yeah so what I'm saying is if you
don't touch the 600 in seven years if
it's in good mutual funds it'll be 1.2
million
and in seven more years it'll be 2.4
right it'll double every seven years if
it's in good mutual funds making ten
percent
that's just a that's a rule of thumb you
can take with a lump sum and always
remember that so you know pretty quickly
you've got a couple million dollars here
in your 70s in a paid for house that's
gone from five or six hundred up to uh
probably a million dollars during that
time in value as well so you've done a
great job way to go pretty cool Ken it's
amazing and you sit there and you know
he wants permission and I always like
these calls and I actually throw it back
to you because I think a lot of our
audience there's some psychology there
why is it that when he's in that kind of
financial shape still feels that need
for permission what's behind that well
he he's been very
um wise and
he's a marathoner not a sprinter he's
the tortoise he's not the hair
and that's how he got to this level yeah
so he got to be in a baby steps
millionaire and everyday millionaire and
um those guys they don't take many steps
back
they only take steps forward that's
right because they're wise and they're
careful and he was you know it was just
a phrasing he needed my permission but
what he was saying was is this wise
right I don't I don't want to take steps
back I don't want to be rash yeah
because rash is not something that that
guy has ever been that's true yeah a lot
of wisdom and that's how he got to be a
millionaire by the way all you rash
people about Bitcoin oh too soon you
know that's it yeah and you know and and
invested with Bernie Madoff you know and
all that kind of stuff so that that's
the the thing that keeps most people
from getting wealth becoming wealthy is
not the their their uh inability to earn
money and invest it it's they keep doing
stupid butt stuff that sets them back
and they get penalty Strokes right and
the penalty Strokes are what kill you
because you you know you Jack the ball
out of bounds and then you can't find it
it's in a swamp and so you know you but
it went a long way yeah right that's
true you know and so that's it's a
penalty stroke and if that guy doesn't
get penalty Strokes he hits down the
middle right playing golf analogy right
yeah and it's not a real long drive old
man golf but it's just it's
never misses by the way that's Dave and
I'm still playing young man golf
swinging for the fences
did you just say I'm playing oh man God
no is that what you just said that on
the radio well I said you put it right
down Coleman you are like an arcade game
many times when I play with you he gets
up there quack right down the middle
quack play golf I just started all right
false humility Troy is uh in Louisville
Kentucky hi Troy welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hello Dave thanks for taking my call
sure what's up I'll just uh give you the
run down here I'm 41 years old
I have a hundred and eighty six thousand
dollars in debt
I got twelve thousand three hundred
dollars in my emergency fund
and my weekly income bring home pay is
600 a week
and
the debt is two properties one is a
rental house and one is my house I'm
living in
what's the rental house worth what's the
rental house worth
uh about 75 to 80. and what do you owe
on it
uh 45. you're not gonna like me
you're too broke to own a rental house
it owns you you're not making any money
I'd sell that thing
by the time you've got vacancy by the
time you got credit problems by the time
you got a heat and air going out you're
not making any money
and and you're spending a lot of your
dadgum life screwing with this thing I'd
get rid of that I love rentals but I
don't like them that much
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Coleman Ramsay personality is my co-host
today number one best-selling author of
the book paycheck to purpose
which by the way makes a great Christmas
gift at
ramsaysolutions.com in case you couldn't
tell debt-free screams are kind of a big
deal around here folks who stand on this
stage doing their debt-free screamer
Heroes they choose to live like no one
else now they're in a position to live
and give like no one else and that's why
we've started giving everyone who does
their debt-free Scream the live and give
box it's the tool kit That'll Walk out
the whole baby steps Journey for living
and giving like no one else the rest of
your life and now it's not just for debt
free screamers we're offering it for
sale the live and give box has three
things The Total Money Makeover book The
Baby Steps millionaires book which you
should become one and Financial Peace
University for one year all for just 99
by the way but entropist University is
usually 99 so that just kind of gives
you an idea of the discount hey it's a
great deal if you're debt free and you
want to buy the live and give box keep
the baby steps millionaires book give
away the Total Money Makeover book and
go through financial Peace University or
let someone else go through it you got
three gifts two gifts whatever keep one
for yourself it's a great idea here we
go the live and give box at
ramseysolutions.com that's
ramseysolutions.com box
Jordan is with us in Casper Wyoming hi
Jordan welcome to the Ramsay show
hey Dave hey Ken hi hey what's up
and resume template help my husband go
from a QA supervisors and app developer
Apprentice in one year so thank you very
much wow that's awesome how much of a
financial bump did he get
well he's only gotten five now because
it was a lateral transition but whenever
he graduates from the apprenticeship he
should get about 15 there we go all
right fantastic way to go very cool
thank you my question is we are in baby
step five and I'm wondering how you
would advise us to invest for our two
kids ages one and four so my parents
have opened and contribute monthly to an
upma for both of them and they're also
Cherokee Nation citizens and will
receive free college on the reservation
all the way through their doctorate if
they so choose to go that way so as
their parents how do we invest for them
considering their college is covered and
we and they have an utma being invested
in every month
well all in utma is is just like a
mutual fund account or a savings account
that is in their name
and someone sets themselves up as the
custodian so I guess your parents are
the custodian of that account
um so you there you can do an unlimited
number of utmas you're just opening an
account in the kid's name that's all it
is uniform transfer to minors Act
and so you also could do utmas if you
want the advantage of the utma is the
mutual fund being in their name is taxed
at their rate which is much lower than
your rate when once it starts making
some money
and the disadvantages when they're 21
years old it's their money
if they're doing cocaine it's their
money
and so we used to laugh at our house and
you can get uh canceled for this now but
we would laugh at our house and go uh
and so let the beatings begin right so I
mean you got to raise good kids or
you're just you're going to screw them
up with this account right and so uh
that that's the
the deal and uh
we used utmost when our kids were little
because there was no 529s
they didn't exist so we just opened
mutual funds in their names and grew
them for their college funds and
um and actually the weird thing was we
never ended up using it for college we
just gave it to them after they got
married well it's already theirs because
they were 21. uh and uh we turned the
paperwork over to them so they could
find it
um but uh after they got married and
then we just paid for college we just we
just cash flowed college but so if they
uh on the uh Cherokee scholarship thing
if they uh don't go to college on the
reservation
that does not apply right
that's correct today they'd be eligible
for various scholarships depending on
what they do and what they study and if
they can if they commit to working for
the Cherokee Nation they can also get
more money that way but they would not
be fully covered right okay
so
um
I I just want to give I want to put some
options that they may choose to go to
school if they had money somewhere else
and so I'm going to build some money up
you know if I'm you you need to do 529
or you can do an Atma either one
um
the interesting thing is this uh if you
did a 529 and then they did go on the
reservation the value of the scholarship
can be removed from the 529 tax-free
every year
okay and so whatever the cost of college
let's say it's ten thousand dollars to
go to school there a year tuition you
can pull that out of the 529 without
paying any taxes on it or any kind of
scholarships for that matter if they got
scholarships say uh because just because
they had uh some Cherokee blood of X
percentage right uh that that would
qualify them by the way for a lot of
different kinds of scholarships that
have nothing to do with the Cherokee
Nation
but just Native American blood uh over 1
16 they'll qualify you for a ton
of different scholarships so uh because
a lot of stuff is aimed at different
things like that minorities of different
kinds so yeah it's wonderful I take
advantage of all that Christina Ellis uh
you know she utilized that big time when
she went and got 500 000 worth of
scholarship so if they went got
scholarships just because of that all of
that money can be taken out of the 529
also so these kids have got it made in
terms of options and I'm going to
probably use the 529 now that I've sat
here and talked myself into it because
there because I can get a lot of the
money back out I wouldn't over fund it I
wouldn't put 200 000 in 529 but I would
have 50 to 100 in there
okay
and that way it's growing tax-free
knowing that just about any Direction
they choose to go they're going to be
able to remove money from there based on
the value of the scholarship they go
whatever Direction it is even if they
promise to work back for the nation and
the nation paid for school that's a
scholarship
I love that tax-free uh uh provision and
I hope the government leaves it alone
for crying out loud oh yeah they're
smart enough to figure it out I mean
but that is a great provision I love
that Brandon is in New York City hi
Brandon how are you
hey Dave and Ken good afternoon
afternoon what's up
so I I have a couple things going on I
just want some some guidance
um my wife and I actually just paid off
uh 180 000 of student loans Wow way to
go and
thank you thank you so during that time
caused my investing um to try and get it
paid off as soon as possible and so now
we like I mentioned we have a couple
things going on I I have a my first our
first child coming in February yay
um thank you and
top of that our our landlords are kind
of old so we're kind of living on Far
time right now we're renting still so
we're saving up for a house at the same
time
so my question is you know I feel like I
almost have like a year left in this
place and so I'm looking for guidance on
when I should start you know
contributing back to my retirement again
considering I have basically two other
life events that are going on I have a
kid coming in February and we're trying
to save it for a house before debt free
right I'm not drawn on the streets but
are you debt-free we're debt free good
for you the 130 got you clear good well
done all right then you have an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses and then you're gonna pile up
money for a down payment as fast as you
can and in the meantime you're going to
delay starting retirement we call that
baby step 3B and that's perfectly fine I
wouldn't delay it more than three years
and you're not going to
okay so far it's been two years so
that's why I'm getting no no you were
delaying before you were delaying it for
other reasons for two years I'm talking
about delaying it in order to save a
down payment
yeah which starts really
now I mean that didn't start back in the
couple years ago you're still paying off
debt
yeah exactly yeah that's not the
equation I'm talking about I'm talking
about once you're debt free and you have
your emergency fund then I'm going to
start saving for my down payment how
long would I delay retirement in order
to really beef up the down payment a
maximum of three years
okay and that's including the last few
years no that's starting now once you
have your emergency fund in place
starting after you're debt free and
after your emergency fund's in place
once you start start putting money into
the down payment account that from then
on three years and you're not going to
do it longer than three years because
you're just telling you're just talking
to me about a year
and so you're not and and you know if it
goes much longer than that and you want
to start up your retirement account
later you can you got plenty of time
you're going to do both well your
congratulations it's all going to be
good
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
Solutions on the debt free stage Allison
and Stephen are with us hey guys how are
you great great how are you better than
I deserve where do you guys live Merry
Christmas we're from New Jersey all
right good to have you fun fun welcome
to Nashville and down here to do a debt
free scream how much have you paid off
138 thousand dollars love it and how
long did that take about 26 months good
for you and your range of income during
that two years
we started off around 180 plus bonus and
now we're at 250 plus bonus cool what do
you all do for a living
I'm in human resources
Senior Systems administrator for a
subsidiary of Nationwide Insurance good
for you well done guys great careers
good for you fun what kind of debt was
the 138
it was a combination uh we had
a credit card personal loan 401k loan
student loan it was everything we had a
boat yes we had a boat yes
that was that was the big you know we
sold that and we were able to pay off a
lot of debt with that we made more than
what we paid for it so wow that was a
big boat yes exactly yeah yeah there's a
moment in time
like cars went up yeah that's crazy yeah
yeah it's like the Mississippi flowed
backwards you know
wow hey good job what'd the boat sell
for uh we sold it for about 28 000. okay
good lick nice yeah kind of kind of cry
just a little bit yeah a little bit we
miss it every day a lot of good memories
on it but you know this this was more
important but now you make a quarter
million dollars a year and you know I
mean debt you can save up and buy one
right I'll buy one cash yeah yeah and
they craft better when they don't like
payments yeah I've noticed that myself
yeah so cool guys all right so you're
kind of normal you had a bunch your debt
how long you all been married about five
years okay and so
about halfway into your marriage about
two and a half years in you look up and
say ah tell me about it what happened
what got you started on this Ramsey
stuff so actually one of my co-workers
uh gave us gave it as a wedding gift so
that was five years ago when we yeah but
it was a coaster it was a coaster on the
coffee table yes we would look at it we
went to Financial Peace we had a nun was
teaching us at a local church and you
know we did the whole cut up your credit
cards and we just we tried but we
weren't fully into it and then um about
two years ago we said all right let's
get back into it let's start working on
it and then actually last year my
brother passed away and it was a reality
check to us because we were saying you
know we were always living life as YOLO
you only live once we were going on
vacation spending money and then we said
you know what this is not the life that
we want to live we do want more things
we want a great house we want to buy a
nice house we want a great life for our
daughter so that was our Turning Point
how old is your daughter five okay very
good wow so when you finally decide okay
this time we're going all in yeah uh I'd
love it I mean we're going to sell the
boat that's right yeah yeah nobody's
questioning that commitment yeah I'm
just curious tell the audience uh what
did you do to drive the intensity when
you said all right we we kind of got
this thing now we're all in what'd that
look like
well not going out to eat was a big one
um only you know for special occasions
and we really got into thrifting yeah so
we were going to thrift stores we were
buying all our clothes from there yeah
um you know what let me ask you this
because this is real stuff here what
would you uh say and you're making 190
Grand buying your clothes with thrift
stores I love you yeah how much money
were you saving by buying clothes from
Thrift I'm just curious a lot a lot a
lot probably probably five seven hundred
a month five seven hundred a month
that's a big chunk yeah wow yeah
do you still buy Thrift clothes oh yeah
that's the only way we'll do it forever
that's where you got that hoodie that's
life hacker yeah
find these wealthy neighborhoods and go
to the thrift stores in them they got
great stuff yeah wow I'll be right back
Dave you handle the rest of this call
I'll be right back I mean garage sales
in the rich neighborhood like an eight
thousand dollar yeah uh leather couch
for 50 or 60 bucks yeah I mean you know
yeah it's crazy that's awesome yeah
you guys are incredible well done how
does it feel to be free uh feels great
yes it's a feeling that we've never
really had before we're starting a new
life really it's when you sold the boat
and people say you've lost your now
that's it you've gone too far well when
I told them I made money on it they said
well okay now we understand why you sold
it but I think they were more upset than
we were because they weren't coming on
the boat yeah yeah
yeah
that's exactly what I think like a
friend with a boat or a pickup yeah yeah
that's great yeah yeah you can
freeloaders
all right when someone says how do you
pay off debt what do you tell them the
key is
you know we tell them budget that's was
the biggest thing for us I think we just
we're watching money come out of our
account didn't really know where it was
going and now I track it down to the
penny and it's really helped out it's
really it's been an eye-opener to see
where our money goes and then to see
these payments just drop off and be done
and now I'm saving that money and now
all these payments that I had you know
we had probably seven eight payments a
month now we have none yeah and it's
insane how fast your savings account
will grow
I met a guy many many years ago he said
one of his goals was to get more mutual
fund statements in his mailbox than
bills oh I like that that's nice yeah I
want the right kind of mail wow you know
so it's a different thing yeah get rid
of the bills you don't you know what are
we going to do with it that's it's a
Pretty stinking cool thing so very very
well done guys I'm pretty impressed with
you you're amazing Heroes who was
cheering you on other than the two of
you
um our family you know my parents our
parents
um a couple of friends
yeah but it was really it really was the
two of us you know yeah getting aligned
and it helped our marriage and yeah we
really got on the same page and you know
we never looked back and we who gave you
financial peace or what was it or Total
Money Makeover for a wedding gift uh one
of my co-workers did oh that you said
that okay did they know you did all this
now no no since then have left the
company but I'm sure they'll be watching
so yeah they'll see me now that you're a
YouTube Star yeah yes very good guys
very very good hey we've got a copy of
Total Money Makeover for you the baby
steps Millionaires and a one-year
membership to financial peace now you
can be that co-worker that gives some of
it away the live and give bundle and uh
way to go very very very proud of you
good times good times all right it's
Allison and Stephen from Newark New
Jersey 138 000 paid off in 26 months
making 180 to 250 count it down let's
hear a debt free scream
[Applause]
thank you
well done you guys I love it that is how
it's done
yeah you have to have an I've had it
moment to turn the corner on this it
doesn't work otherwise and uh you gotta
have that moment and you know it's funny
you can kind of go along and be ish on
anything yeah Ramsey stuff hunting your
job hunting a new job putting up with
whatever but then something happens in
the switch flips and something happens
in any time I mean I've kind of been a
study a student for 30 years of
transformation of Hope and and what
happens that causes hope to kick in
to the point that you get energized and
you're willing to sacrifice yeah and you
know you listen to their story it was
the loss of a loved one a sibling and
you just start to go okay life is short
life is precious and how do I want to
live my life what do I want to uh be
told about me and you know it's funny
because you've said for years and years
and years and years decades if you live
like no one else later you can live and
give like no one else and it's you've
said things like change your family
treat and if you just get to the root of
everything that I think you're saying
there it's really about what kind of
Life do I want to live that's in the now
and then what kind of Life do I want to
lead and leave behind and I think that's
a powerful story from their journey is
that it made them take inventory and say
huh yeah I don't want to live this way
anymore there's something existential
like the old motivational speaker used
to say there's two dates on your
Tombstone the beginning when you're born
the end when you die neither one of
those matter what matters is what you do
with the dash what are you gonna do with
your dash so good what are you gonna do
with that Dash in between them that's it
and what that's what you're gonna be
known for is not diet it's not the date
of birth or date of death neither one
it's what did you do with the dash and
that's something existential about that
that there's a wake-up call and you
finally say that's it selling the boat
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs 10 12
hatred stirs up conflict
but love covers over all wrongs
Martin Luther King Jr said let no man
pull you so low as to hate him
Jacob is with us Jacob is in Austin
Texas hi Jacob welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hey guys thanks for having me I
appreciate it sure what's up
uh so I actually heard about you about a
year ago from my electrician he uh him
and his wife they they paid off
I think it was eighty four thousand
dollars in about 18 months so once you
told me that I bought your book and I'm
on baby step two right now cool um so I
should say thanks for what you're doing
that's awesome thank you
um but I was calling today just for some
uh some advice I guess you would call it
but I'm a project manager here in Austin
we build um luxury homes in in Austin
and you know with the market it's kind
of you know kind of scary with with how
things are going we have some unsold
homes they're all specs but my question
is you know I love my company I love who
I work for but I don't have any new
starts coming up so should I sit down
and talk with my boss about my future
here with the company or should I you
know look for other jobs just to just to
cover myself
so the reason behind this is you feel
like you may get laid off because you
have no starts in the in the pipeline
yeah so I've only been here for about a
year and three months now and I used to
start last year job at least one job
every two months and I haven't gotten a
uh a new start in about I think four or
five months now so they haven't really
told me about my future with what have
you been doing or have you got other
project still underway you're wrapping
up
yeah yeah I do so I have I have two more
that I'm wrapping up they will both be
done by January yeah
well I got to tell you I think it's both
and I I think that not looking to leave
but just looking uh it's it's kind of
like you know when you get on an
airplane and before we all take off they
say all right here's where your exits
are I think it's smart to always know
certainly in a situation like this where
you're kind of trying to read the tea
leaves
um to be looking at what an exit
strategy would look like this is just
about being prepared but I would also
have the conversation with your leader
to say hey I just want to talk about a
growth plan I wouldn't go in with a lot
of negatives you know and assume
anything I would just never want to put
your leader on a defensive you don't
want to say things like well I'm
thinking of this and I'm seeing this I
don't worry about this I just go and go
Hey listen
um you know I want to grow and I love
what I'm doing and I love this place and
you said that on this call so speak you
know honestly about how you like it what
you like and say hey what does a growth
plan look like and let's just see what
the reaction is you can tell if
somebody's kicking the can down the road
in front of you
um is there a negative of just saying uh
okay my projects are running out and I
just want to I just want to you know
take a temperature of what's going on I
want to be a good team member yeah and
um I'm obviously noticing that I don't
have anything in the pipeline and what
can I do to add value if we don't have
stuff in the pipeline yeah I think do a
version of that I think I would say hey
I'm looking at my starts and I'm looking
at our schedule and I'm just wondering
what the future looks like on a good
good idea what the short term looks like
and then I also want to talk about
growing up what can I do to them what
can I help while we're going through
this rough patch yes I would do that uh
I would not you know I need my turn
around and go look you don't get any
starts you're going to be gone get ready
all right yeah which by the way which by
the way that's right that's a good thing
and and if a leader will be honest with
you like that to say hey honestly uh
Jacob I don't know it's 50 50. that's
great news because now you can begin to
act so I would do both I'd have a good
conversation transparent humble hungry
is what you're trying to uh posture
there and then I'd be looking for other
opportunities so that you're ready yeah
it's um
you know and you never know what'll come
of it uh it doesn't cost anything to
look at the menu no no you don't have to
order just look at the menu and do not
panic right don't jump you know Dave and
I were talking about this earlier don't
panic you know and move to a company
that may not be a good culture because
you're going to regret that you don't
sound rattled yeah and so I think you
won't sound rattled when you're meeting
with your leader but if you had two job
offers in your pocket you would sound
less rattled that's right when you met
with your leader uh because you know
options give you power
and options give you courage and uh not
to be cocky or arrogant with your leader
but just I mean literally what happens
it changes your body language it changes
your voice tone when you're scared you
go up a half an octave when you're
really scared you go up two octaves and
so uh you can change the way you sit it
changes the way you walk in the room
you're looking over your shoulder you
know looking for that uh corporate knife
in the back all that kind of stuff
speaking of which Chris is on the line
Chris is in Phoenix Chris tell me what
in the world is going on there
hi guys thanks for taking my call sure
um I just wanted to ask should I apply
to or basically my company is offering a
voluntary layoffs that you're going to
do math Lighthouse right now
um so I don't even know if my job is on
the line but I already feel a poll to go
ahead and leave my company and then
needing to are they offering Severance
packages to get you out
uh it's just nine weeks of pay
what do you make
80k how long you been there
almost four years what do you do
the pipe team are you thinking about
leaving them before this came about
yes I um I take the nine weeks I'd find
something as quick as you can and take
the nine weeks man this is not healthy
you know for you because you already
were thinking of leaving you don't know
nothing exudes Confidence from
leadership like paying people to leave
right
it's like the it's like the announcement
hey we've got a overbooked flight we'll
give you a 500 voucher if you get off of
this flight and wait for the next one
it's it's a whole different ball game
there you know there's an actual
advantage and blah blah blah blah blah
but this is like uh there's nothing good
about this
so I take the deal and not the can I not
be scared because I don't have any
offers right now
um
you're in supply chain for God's sakes
you can get an offer within 10 days
how okay let's walk through this
practically I understand what you're
saying but how many offers can you get
by Christmas well the deadlines today so
I just want to make sure yeah
interesting part of the conversation
yeah it would have been nice to know I
don't have to I don't have to apply for
it but it's probably going to be the
easiest way to make this news so you
would be laid off so let me let me ask
you this if you say yes today are you
laid off tomorrow
probably 80 20 likely
all right we'll cut a financial position
are you in right now
we have an emergency fund I'm not
concerned about the finances yeah by the
way let me just say let me just say this
emergency funds
are not to be used for someone who can't
go get a job and if you had to go get a
job delivering something something until
we land the next thing and start getting
the nine weeks don't touch the emergency
fund in this situation because I don't
think you need to how sure are you you
can land a supply chain job by the end
of January
I'm very confident by the end of January
I wouldn't say by the end of this month
all right yeah anyway I would say you I
would give you a 90 probability if you
know your stuff you'd be landing
something
would you agree with that I mean I did I
did find this job in two weeks earlier
this year so
I'm pretty confident in my ability how
much is in your emergency fund
30k and um are you married
yes what does she make
90k
take the layoff yeah yeah right that's
exactly right 90k 30k in the bank you're
going to get nine weeks you got a 90
probability of Landing a new gig by the
end of January take the deal
all right does that make sense to you
you see the you see the variables
yep and just I want to drive a nail in
this can you live off of your wife's
income from a bill standpoint
yeah definitely don't touch the
emergency fund don't go work a side
hustles yes you can that's right don't
touch the emergency there you go you're
the man that's exactly it so Chris you
know you're not happy there they're not
they're they're failing they're
struggling they're weird they're
whatever they are who whatever puts you
in a position you're
we're asking people to apply to be laid
off I mean I can't even imagine making
this announcement I I want to know I
wonder if that's fear it's like okay we
don't want to actually lay anybody off
if we don't have to let's see if we can
get some volunteers quite firing
I think it's cowardly firing well that's
quiet yeah it's quiet quitting is
cowardly quitting let's see if we can
get anybody to volunteer that'll be less
awkward
[Laughter]
I guess I don't know the whole thing's
awkward yeah there you go Ken Coleman
good job today thank you sir Jenna Ben
Austin Zach and Andrew in the booth well
done I'm Dave Ramsey your host will be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
foreign
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
Ramsay Network wherever you listen to
podcasts